[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue d'un point de vue tout
de suite notre sommaire en images le son
du clip pendez les blancs on peut s'en
passer lui même si on en parle beaucoup
depuis hier on s'arrêterait en revanche
sur cette question le racisme anti-blanc
n'est-il pas devenu une marque de
fabrique d'une partie du rap français
c'est d'après temps du mépris de
l'apport de la province qu il sera aussi
question celui de long les élus locaux
accusent le gouvernement a tort a raison
le premier ministre a lui tenté ce matin
marseille d'expliquer représentants des
régions qui n'était pas maltraités par
le gouvernement qui sera le prochain
procureur de paris pour le bras aucun
des candidats ne satisfait manuel macron
qui l'a fait savoir
et il a été aussitôt soupçonné de porter
atteinte à l'indépendance de la justice
enfin l'aquarius la solution européenne
trouvé mardi est elle la bonne naissent
au contraire qu'une solution de court
terme
dites nous ce que vous en pensez nous
vous donnerons les résultats d'un
sondage qui paraît demain dans le figaro
sur le sujet bonjour lucile schmid un
bonjour marc hennerici beaucoup nous
avoir rejoints vous êtes co président de
la fondation verte européenne après
avoir fait de la politique au parti
socialiste et europe écologie les verts
mais tu besoin de vous présenter vous
est une habituée de point de vue bonjour
ferghana ziari journaliste analyste en
politiques publiques vous collaborez à
plusieurs think tank dont l'institut de
recherches économiques et fiscales
merci d'être avec nous bonjour cécile
crouzet la journaliste au figaro chef
adjoint du service macroéconomie france
et bonjour ivan rioufol éditorialiste
hauteur du bloc notes du vendredi
bloc-notes qui si je ne me trompe
s'intitule demain la victimisation
passeport pour le pouvoir et vous
alerter sur le piège de la victimisation
on va en parler justement tout de suite
avec cette affaire du clip pendez les
blancs un clip aux paroles ultra
violente qui a fait sortir de l'anonymat
le dénommé ni conrad malgré le tollé le
rapport
le rappeur se justifie par tout en
expliquant que tout cela n'est que de la
fiction
une enquête a été ouverte par le parquet
de paris alors des morceaux de rap et ne
voire raciste ça existe on le sait
faut-il être beaucoup plus vigilant
ça ce racisme anti blanc c'est en tout
cas l'avis de nicolas dupont aignan
nicolas dupont aignan qui est président
de debout la france etc était ce matin
sur europe 1 on écoute c'est le signe
d'une dégradation très profonde et des
rapports sociaux dans notre pays
ça fait des années que le racisme
anti-blanc aigner et n'est pas puni
comme l'autre racisme il ya un moment
notre société doit dire stop à ce
déferlement de haine quels qu'ils soient
d'où qu'ils viennent
si le cucs clans se promener place de la
concorde
bien évidemment réagir et donc moi je
veux pas de cuques scandale envers lui
si on va peut-être pas revenir sur le
clip lui même la frontière entre liberté
d'expression et incitation à la haine
en revanche on a sous-estimé le racisme
anti-blanc véhiculées par cette forme de
rap
écoutez moi ce qui me frappe c'est qu'on
se mette à découper le racisme c'est à
dire que je crois que le racisme
il n'est ni en petits blancs ni anti
noir il existe et il est une négation de
la différence et donc moi je m'élève
contre ce qu'ils aiment ce que dit
nicolas dupont aignan il n'y a pas de
racisme anti blanc et de racisme anti
noir il ya du racisme tout simplement et
je crois que pour pouvoir le combattre
il faut garder des concepts des mots qui
en fait s'adresse à l'ensemble de la
société française c'est à dire que si
maintenant on découpe le racisme par
appartement et que ensuite on va en
justice sur ce genre de concept je crois
que la république
elle va mal donc je crois que ça c'est
un point qui est essentiel après il ya
la question de la violence de ces
paroles qui ont été qui ont d'ailleurs
permis à un inconnu sans talent de
devenir célèbre en un tournemain
et ça ça s'est passé grâce à des hommes
politiques plutôt des hommes que des
femmes si j'ai bien compris qu'ils
eurent qui l'on nous fait allusion à
bruno retailleau notamment où il ya
effectivement été le premier à alerter
sur l'un des premiers l'occasion à bruno
retailleau et je fais allusion à nicolas
dupont aignan convient de voir et on
allait il fallait pas alors j'aimerais
que ivan rioufol vous répondre il ne
fallait pas parler de ce clip
mais j'espère que ces deux solutions qui
vont préciser votre pensée mais ma
puissance rapport à le préciser ce que
je pense c'est cadet il ya des clips il
ya du rap qui est extrêmement talentueux
est qu il se trouve que là la classe
politique
une certaine classe politique réagit
avec beaucoup de virulence sans
connaître le rap est au fond le danger
par rapport à ça c'est que ce soit la
polémique quotidienne
qui à chaque fois au fond qu livres par
rapport à des jeunes et des moins jeunes
par rapport à des noirs et des blancs et
donc je trouve cette polémique assez
artificiel donc je en train de nous dire
que ceux qui ont dénoncé ce clip ignoble
sur les coupables il ya quand même là
une inversion des priorités qui est tout
à fait révélateur de ce qu'est
aujourd'hui le politiquement correct et
de ce qu'est la dénaturation de
l'antiracisme parce que l'antiracisme
précisément a fait évacuer tout perdre
perspectives de mise en responsabilité
des minorités
quand elle même s'adonner à du racisme
c'est ainsi qu'on a fermé les yeux
depuis les années 2000 sur
l'antisémitisme des cités sur le sexisme
dans les cités sur la violence dans les
cités sur le racisme anti blanc dans les
cités naturellement et donc fin de
découvrir aujourd'hui qu'il y avait tout
ce ça tout cela dans le rap qui était un
peu le vecteur identitaire si je puis
dire de toute cette violence et de tout
ce racisme concentré face auquel il
était de bon temps de fermer les yeux au
prétexte que c'était des minorités donc
des victimes et moi je me suis je suis
ravi de voir qu'enfin aujourd'hui on
ouvre les yeux mais il y avait déjà eu
des rappeurs qui nous avait déjà alerté
je me souviens par exemple d'une
interview de doc gyneco en 2006 domine
2007 qui nous disait que le rap était un
vecteur de l'islamisation un vecteur de
l'islamisme il y met nous mettait même
en alerte sur les paroles de médine à
l'époque en 2007 en disant que médine
était un fauteur de guerre
on n'a pas voulu l'entendre on est il
s'est fait insulter à l'époque
souvenez-vous sans doute et on se rend
compte aujourd'hui bien sûr que healy a
effectivement que de l'anti racisme a
produit du racisme alors d'un côté lucy
ne dit pas de race pas de
compartimentalisation comment dire vous
vous dites le racisme anti blanc il
existe yvan ferghana ziari j'aimerais
avoir votre opinion là dessus mais avant
je réponds pas à l'écran les propos de
barbara lefebvre baba lefebvre c'est
cette enseignante en histoire-géographie
qui est proche de cai coécrit les
territoires perdus de la république qui
donnait une interview ce matin au figaro
et qui disait ni conrad et dieudonné
joue les méchants provocateur et de
gentils zico de la diversité répète sur
les plateaux télé que tout ça est
regrettable mais que c'est la faute aux
discriminations et à la colonisation
je comprends la nécessité aujourd'hui
effectivement 2
de de s'attarder sur ce qu'on appelle le
racisme anti blanc même si idéalement je
pense effectivement il ne pourrait pas
segmenter entre les différentes formes
du racisme c'est vrai qu'on a l'habitude
aujourd'hui dans le discours notamment
d'une certaine gauche entendent que le
raciste serait le monopole d'une ethnie
particulière et de que par conséquent il
n'existerait pas de l'autre côté de la
barrière ethnique
or aujourd'hui on conseille évidemment
que aucune la population aucune
catégorie de population n'a le monopole
de la haine ni de la discrimination
donc sur ce sujet là effectivement je
pense que c'est normal d'en parler
maintenant moi je suis pas à l'aise avec
l'idée de d'essentialiser telle ou telle
forme d'art
le rap est de généraliser comme ça en
disant que toute une catégorie serait le
vecteur de l'islamisation ou d'une
revendication identitaire il ya autant
dans un courant musical il ya autant de
temps dans deux prises de position que
beaucoup de rappeurs et je pense que
généraliser ça effectivement un
phénomène si je ne connaissais pas le
rappeur dont je parle aujourd'hui
personne ne connaissait l'existence
hier en même temps vous bon et d'un côté
il est ce un effet kim ok cette
indignation parce que en admettant qu'il
ne faille pas le condamner pénalement
juridiquement c'est à la société civile
par la pression sociale par
l'indignation effectivement de
sanctionner socialement tel ou tel
propos inacceptables
mais d'un autre côté je vous demande si
quelque part le buzz n'était pas
recherché on en est effectivement c'est
regrettable à faire la promotion de
quelqu'un d'un type qui était
insignifiant encore il ya quelques jours
alors en parlait pas en parler c'est si
je suis un peu partagé on monte entre
les deux points de vue parce
qu'effectivement c'est à je pense que
c'est quand même vrai on en parle parce
que c'est révélateur d'un problème de
société
il y a quand même une montée de une
sorte de haine quand même en france auto
différentes catégories
je passe un peu trop forme il ya
beaucoup de tension entre entre autres
un chat un chat et catégories sociales
certaines quêtes et en france entre
certains quartiers etc
il ya quand même beaucoup beaucoup de
tension on a l'impression qu'on est dans
une société de plus en plus clivée donc
à la fois ils font ça radicaux parce que
ça rejoint
un phénomène de société profond je pense
que c'est pour ça que ça a un écho en
même temps effectivement là on met en
avant encore une fois quelqu'un de
médiocres de haineux de voilà
et on essaye de lui qu'on est en avant
et on met pas en avant peut-être
d'autres personnes qui c'est mon côté a
peut-être un peu bisounours mais des
personnes qui oeuvrent pour le bien qu
il faut des choses positives celle là on
n'en parle jamais on ne parle que des
gens médiocres
c'est pour ça que je suis un peu balancé
quoi c'est en deux temps en arrivant
vous répondrais révélateur de cet excès
quand même que l'on a constaté à travers
naturellement pas tout le rap je suis
d'accord avec vous faisons la différence
il ya du rap qui n'est pas violent mais
enfin le rap dont on parle c'est le rap
violence et pour sa colère je ne veux
pas faire des généralisations boxe avait
facebook où il vend alors ce n'est
qu'une petite anthologie entre
guillemets du rap anti-français et sans
doute pas du tout représentatif de mais
il ya quand même c'est vrai certain
nombre de propos alors j'en cite
quelques uns je ne mérite pas forcément
d'être cité d'ailleurs juste pour
montrer que le groupe sniper faut que ça
pète frère je lance un appel on est là
pour tous [ __ ] la france ô france est
enregistré ça sera impossible leur
laisser des traces et des séquelles
avant de vous les crever faut leur en
faire baver de là la seule chose qu'ils
ont mérité bon alors le groupe traqueur
je ne connais pas la fois comme ça alors
mais au delà nous avons nous avons
failli assister au bataclan au concert
d'un de ce rappeur qui s'appelle bed-in
qui a fait un disque qui s'appelle jihad
dans celui qui n'ont dont les paroles
notamment apple a crucifié les laïcs a
donc avec un appel à la violence que
l'on a voulu édulcorer en disant c'est
de l'art c'est du rap c'est s'est passé
par tradition de le déprogrammer au
bataclan mais il doit passer en concert
dont louis mais qui passent en concert
ailleurs c'est très bien mais parce que
la solution après tout pourquoi pourquoi
je suis content je suis prêtre à servir
au bataclan c'était quand même une sorte
de briller bien le symbole que
représente aujourd hui le bataclan qui a
été quand même le lieu du martyre
d'individus des djihadistes et des
différents jouets ils faire chanter
quelqu'un qui kiffent utile qui chante
l'autre du johnny avec la quand même
malgré tout une incongruité pour le mois
j'emploie j'emploie un mot faible mais
non c'est pour vous dire que nous ne
sommes pas nous ne sommes pas armés pour
avoir l'esprit suffisamment critique sur
ce que l'on a sous les yeux et on nous
avions sous les yeux avec médine déjà un
appel à goutte j'ai hâte qu'on n'a pas
voulu voir
et aujourd'hui je me félicite même si ce
type en effet ne méritait pas d'être
connu et je me félicite que l'on regarde
enfin en face ce qu'est ce racisme anti
l'anc est une réalité lucile schmid sur
le côté justement diffusion au site sera
pas la question du jour du figaro et
celle ci faut-il infliger une amende aux
plateformes numériques qui ont diffusé
le clip de nick conrad vous êtes 90% à
répondre sur lefigaro.fr
oui il faut aussi punir les plateformes
et on le sait ça a commencé
ça n'a pas été alors ils vont pas de nom
mais s'ils ont répondu après ils vont
moi je suis parisien que moi je trouve
que la liberté d'expression permet au
contraire de regarder en face toutes les
réalités parce qu'il n'y a rien de plus
commode que d'interdire d'occulter de
dire ben non il ne se passe rien voyez
on n'entend rien si il faut entendre il
faut même il faut monstres et j'aime
bien cette expression là qui était
proposée par le sociologue maffesoli
dans parlant du reprenant le vieux mot
français de montres il faut montrer la
réalité dans sa monstruosité et en
l'occurrence si vous êtes pour une
éventuelle condamnation par les
tribunaux mais s'il ya des appels au
meurtre après il faudrait il semblerait
qu'il était quand même là pour cette
fois ci mais je pense qu'il faut laisse
avec toujours cette distinction qui sera
compliqué des avocats le 10 avril
c'était la justice de le dire ce ne sont
pas aux journalistes je suis d'une
position
radicalement différente je pense que les
plateformes ont évidemment une
responsabilité et que la question de la
diffusion et de l'ampleur en fait du
phénomène d'ailleurs c'est comme ça que
ça c'est depuis que ça a été évoqué par
un certain nombre de responsables
politiques c'est comme ça que ça a été
visionné et revisionné moi je voulais
juste dire une chose par rapport à la
façon dont on parle du rap
je pense que ce qui est important en
face à des phénomènes qui sont des
phénomènes de société et les phénomènes
politiques
le rap vous avez des débats on vous
demande si c'est la poésie du 21e siècle
et d'autre on vous explique qu'en fait
c'est quelque chose qui est un appel au
meurtre
donc on est dans une société où au fond
on assure le même sur le même sujet des
débats radicalement différent selon les
milieux où on en parle selon la personne
qui l'analyse selon la génération aussi
et ça je pense que c'est une des
difficultés pour faire fonctionner notre
démocratie
donc moi je trouve que l'ours avant de
parler en général du rap
ce serait assez intéressant de pouvoir
avoir des spécialistes qui nous disent
un petit peu effectivement quel est le
pourcentage la proportion de ces appels
au meurtre ou c'est cette difficulté sur
les paroles
j'aurais quand même pas réussi jean
michel vanasse temps sur le web il faut
pas voir est-ce que je peux aussi ruiné
ma phrase aussi la latitude d'avoir
envie d'écouter du rap qui soit pas
qu'ils soient pas du rap comme tout ce
dont convient d'évoquer jamais écouté
maître gims evianais j'aurais quand même
dire une chose c'est qu'on a pas besoin
d'être noir pour chanter du rap ni
d'être noir pour en écouter
je pense qu'il ya un vrai sujet sur le
fait qu'il faut faire attention à eux
aussi dans nos analyses à ne pas être
raciste il une question pour prolonger
il y avait plusieurs reportages hier
soir évidemment sur le noise il
grand lahou et est doté original rapport
où il a tourné son contrat et
honnêtement dans la cité dont où il vit
les personnes interrogées c'est encore
une fois car portage n'avait aucun recul
1 ct ne prenait pas trop où était le
problème la plupart des jeunes
interrogés
donc ça vient un petit peu mettre un
bémol à ce que vous dites la façon dont
ces reçus et très premier degré quand
même non ce que je pense c'est que il ya
un bémol aussi dès que vous parlez avec
vos enfants adolescents enfin il ya
quelque chose sur des langages
différents la question effectivement de
la prise de distance mais non c'est que
si que çà et là je suis d'accord avec
ivan rioufol sur le fait qu'il faut qu'
une autorité qui disent il ya des choses
qu'on ne fait pas donc la question la
justice elle est importante mais elle
peut pas être chargés de tout ça c'est à
dire que il faut évidemment aussi que
les parents que nous comme comme élément
de structuration de la société on soit
capable de dire non il ya des mots qu'on
emploie pas calquer sur son côté la
justice à son actif une fois vous la
fermer est ce que le mal sera pas fait
entrer que je suis pas du tout d'accord
avec le fait de conférer un rôle à la
justice aux tribunaux dans la régulation
d'allitérations dans la régulation par
dompter les autres artistes et
l'assument de la liberté d'expression et
je pense que je n'y a beaucoup les états
unis pour ça c'est à dire qu'on est un
pays où effectivement on a le droit de
dire des choses les plus horribles mais
la contrepartie c'est qu'une société
civile mais qui prend le relais qui sert
à me dire à qui fait office de pression
sociale régulé par réguler la parole et
je pense que je n'ai nullement confiance
ni aux législateurs
je fais pas confiance au législateur ni
un magistrat pour nous dire ce qu'on a
le droit de dire ou non je pense que
c'est vraiment une affaire de régulation
la société civile ça nécessite comme
certains prérequis culturel ce qu'on les
a en france c'est pas encore certain
mais c'est quelque chose qui se
travaille je pense que mais là faut des
bras séisme c'est pas dur cette année il
faut condamner mais je ne pense pas que
ce soit une bonne idée de confier sa aux
tribunaux parce qu'on suit c'est la
porte ouverte est bien là je suis assuré
de tout à la censure et je pense qu'elle
doit aux réactions je vous redonne la
parole dans un instant anti mac pâte
guillaume nous ont rejoints anti mac les
paroles du rappeur sont ignobles et dire
qu'il a dit que c'étaient des paroles
d'amour quand on n'est pas d'accord
pat le buzz c'est facile comme excuse et
y ajoute de sos racisme at il porté
plainte
guillaume de nantes
guillaume de nantes et le voilà notre
internaute iam a représenté un rap cool
tout quand même si cela ce n'est pas la
faute du rap mais les auteurs des textes
donnent effectivement et quand même lui
offrir une victoire sur les etats-unis
c'est que la haine raciale y est très
présente et qu'il ya des vrais sujets
entre blancs et noirs et que la société
peut-être très régulé mais qu'en tout
cas la violence raciale il ya un niveau
plus élevé qu'en france mais moi je
pense qu'il faut quand même au delà de
ce débat là il faut comprendre quelles
sont les racines de ces phénomènes les
racines de ces phénomènes c'est ce que
l'on peut appeler le politiquement
correct c'est à dire cette victimisation
systématique de toutes les minorités
qu'elles soient sexuelles ethniques ou
religieuses et qui a fait qu'elles ont
été envahis par un sentiment de 2,2
d'inatteignable milices je retrouve pas
le nordine à tamedia d'impunité part
dans la nature
je comprends d'aider roger quand c'est
plus simple en effet et est en effet et
paraît et que la société a été en retour
culpabilisés par le seul fait de d'avoir
à toucher souvenez-vous le slogan de sos
racisme touche pas à mon pote et il ya
eu vraiment des effets pervers à travers
ce slogan da qui a permis enfin dans
venant fait assez à ces minorités de
s'installer sans avoir à rendre compte
de leurs de leur adhésion aux règles
communes d'une république c'est un peu
ceux ci ce sont ses effets là que l'on
voit maintenant apparaître à travers cet
obscurantisme qui était l'un dès le
départ en fin de compte lorsque l'on
observé mais simplement les observateurs
de ce voeu de cet obscurantisme était
désigné comme étant des racistes
précisément parce que c'est les
minorités étaient des minorités
ethniques donc on se mordre la queue et
aujourd'hui il est quand même 5 fressin
que l'on sorte de cet abrutissement du
politiquement correct et bat pour ceux
qui veulent prolonger la réflexion je
vous conseille en avant première je vous
propose maintenant passer à nos deuxième
thème celui donc des régions c'est mal
aimé ou non la calinothérapie d'edouard
philippe pourra-t-elle suffi à rassurer
les élus locaux
c'est pas évident le premier ministre a
prononcé un discours ce matin devant le
congrès des régions à marseille il a
regretté que le lien soit distendu entre
paris et les régions
on en a assez d'être considérés comme
des ploucs de province
mais auparavant alerté xavier bertrand
président de la région au de france
qu'on va écouter ils étaient hier sur
france 2 on en a marre d'être considéré
comme des imbéciles de seconde zone
parce qu'ils décident qu'ils dirigent
à paris on est les ploucs de province
ont des bois rien on n'y connaît rien
sauf que quand même sur nos territoires
que ce soit des maires des élus
départementaux ça fait des années qu'on
bosse et c'est peut-être là sur le
terrain qu'on peut le plus éviter que
les fractures françaises ne s'aggrave le
président de la république pense que il
a raison il a raison tout seul et qu'il
peut tout diriger de paris ça se passe
pas comme ça la ville la france n'est
pas une entreprise qui dirige avec un
conseil d'administration et 15 20
personnes le site 8 l'opposition
paris-province le complexe d'infériorité
de la province les arguments sont pas un
peu éculé quand même non moi je trouve
que je trouve qu'il a raison nous
avaient péri la nasa dévoile à présent
non je crois que ce qui est intéressant
c'est que cette expression de plus qu de
province au fond je regardais il ya
quelques années on l'employait pour
lui-même le revendique et xavier
bertrand c'est à dire que vous avez ya
une fierté aussi être un flic de
province par rapport aux technocrates
parisiens et que là il ya quelque chose
qui en fait résonne fortement dans la
société française on est à un moment où
la verticalité de maquereaux et dénoncer
toutes parts et compris à paris par la
maire de paris etc
donc il ya à mon avis quelque chose qui
est très bien vu en termes de
communication après il faudrait qui
précise qu'il entend par là et notamment
ce qu'il propose d'autre que ce qui se
passe au niveau de l'état donc le sujet
s'est pas seulement ça collait une et
italiens 10 1 600 malades qui semble
vite de se victimiser justement comme
disait ivan rioufol pour ensuite devenir
plus puissant parce que ça ça existe
aussi et xavier bertrand pas seulement
avec les jeunes des cités dont qui dit
ça pour dire moi j'ai des idées moi je
suis proche de vous moi je suis créatif
mais moi j'attends encore de savoir
qu'est ce qu'ils proposent au niveau de
la politique budgétaire la façon dont on
réclame justement sait s'il va peut-être
nous éclairer là dessus parce que c'est
beaucoup une question financière
wayne rooney des provinces des
dirigeants nenê
jeu de dupes là-dedans quoi savent tout
le monde joue son rôle avec avec 1 200
d'état qui est un peu différent parce
qu'il ya deux choses
il ya d'abord l'effort financier qui est
demandé mais les considérablement
moindre que celui qui a été imposée par
françois hollande qui a carrément coupé
dans l'argent que l'état verte elle
souligné et là on leur demande de tenir
leurs dépenses nous en hausse des
dépenses 1 qui sont toujours prévus aux
1,2 pour cent seulement par an donc il
ya un espèce de postures total puisqu'en
fait le look ou le remède est beaucoup
moins fort et même la dérange la glisse
et déjà purgé passé et la cour des
comptes dit que que par ailleurs le même
que le remède imposé par mâcon est passé
n'est pas assez fort ce point de vue là
et puis c'est assez comique parce que je
croyais que j'avais bertrand avait fait
partie de l air qui demandaient des
suppressions de postes des économies
dans les dépenses publiques et c'est
donc là que outils de régulation bah non
ça va plus du tout donc ok je viens
parce que maman dur et l'occident pour
encore plus comique c'est qu'elle se
plaît mais la plupart des grandes
collectivités ont signé ce pacte avec
les quatre des tapas prévoyant de une
rose 1,2 pour cent seulement des
dépenses
ils ont signé même françois baroin et
qu'elle attribue à signer pour 3 donc si
vous voulez et le plouc de province dont
ça ressort français paris-province moi
j'ai une province je sais pas quoi dire
c'est en appel de truites mal aimé
offrir voilà voilà comment on conduit un
ciel
voilà depuis deux siècles c'est habile
comme argument c'est voilà victimise
aussi je vois moi c'est ça allait qu une
certaine justement ils vont être
soucieux des deniers publics a priori
après des années de gabegie de de
dépassement dans tous sens se tendre de
jacobinisme et de reprise en main de
l'état n'est-elle pas ne va-t-elle pas
dans le bon sens
non c'est alors bon il faudra avoir un
raisonnement économique que je ne
maîtrise pas mais moi ce que je vois
c'est que en effet bertrand a raison de
dire qu'il qu'ils sont considérés comme
des pubs pour deux raisons d'abord parce
que en effet le maquereau les considère
comme des ploucs d'ailleurs son ministre
de l'intérieur lui avait reproché sa
trop grande suffisance enfin je ne sais
plus quel était le mots qu'il avait
employés
et puis surtout les décisions qui ont
été prises par par le gouvernement sur
très récemment sont des mauvaises
manières ses dires d'imposer par exemple
80 km/heure adea des départements qui
aurait pu très bien le faire revient me
connaissez mieux les routes que le
également de revenir de venir contredire
les décisions répétitive sur notre dame
des landes de tous et de toutes ces
autorités locales et d'imposer
maintenant le refus d'un aéroport
également a pu être mal compris de la
même manière de priver les municipalités
de la gestion leurs propres impôts avec
la suppression de la taxe d'habitation
montre bien qu'ils louaient un événement
dont consoeurs malgré tout je trouve que
le procès qui est fait à ce gouvernement
d'accentuer le centralisme qui est déjà
vraiment une plaie de mon point de vue
de la france est le pays le plus
centralisée je crois au monde je pense
sous votre contrôle
donc je crois qu'il ya beaucoup d il ya
beaucoup de raisons de dire qu'en effet
ce qu'ils habitent les les provinciaux
dont je suis aussi se peuvent se sentir
mal et missiles comme c'était qu'il
avait fallu un peu serré la vis depuis
paris pour que
je n'ai pas si relais raison là dessus
vous avez vous avez cliqué sur maps et
on va quand même malgré tous il ya dans
cette danse de ce gouvernement e-litige
technocratique qui se renferme sur
lui-même équipé sa faiblesse votre
libéralisme supporter dans quel sens
centralisation décentralisation dans
d'autres c'est vrai que non mais c'est
vrai que souscrit tous au constat mais
moi je m'interroge quand même sur la
sincérité de xavier bertrand parce que
enfin le jacobinisme français ils ne
datent pas des manuels macron certes
effectivement il a peut-être renforcer à
sa manière la centralisation politique
avec on l'a entendu ici les mesures
comme le retrait de la taxe d'habitation
mais enfin il me semble pas avoir
entendu la droite sarkozy critiqué ce
jacobiniste donc j'ai l'impression qu'on
critique la centralisation quand ce
n'est pas nous y sommes au pouvoir c'est
quand même beaucoup ça et donc la
sincérité voudrais qu'on remette
complètement en cause le paradigme
jacobins qui fit effectivement qui
gangrènent à mon sens la politique
française c'est ma vie le principal
frein à la compétitivité des services
publics à l'immobilisme aussi delà de la
france
la raison pour laquelle on n'arrive pas
à réformer parce que tout se décide à
paris tout est sclérosé à partir de la
capitale française
et si on donner davantage de pouvoirs
aux collectivités avec néanmoins une
contrepartie c'est une plus grande
responsabilité budgétaire et notamment
brandir une mutualisation des risques et
des finances bien moindres parce
qu'aujourd'hui effectivement si l'état
un droit de regard sur ce que font les
collectivités c'est parce qu'on sait
très bien que si elle dérive
et bien c'est le contribuable national
oui donc la contrepartie de plus de
compétences de plus de pouvoir s'y aussi
une plus grande responsabilité dans la
gestion est aussi dans la chanson des
difficultés et ça est ce qu'ils sont
prêts à l'assumer mais pas sur quelques
réactions sur ce sujet freddy monsieur b
freddy pardon david bertrand a peut-être
raison mais la décentralisation a aussi
été facteur dans l'es10 mans de nos
campagnes et des abords des villes de
province
un vrai sujet ça je suis sûr qu'il vous
à coeur les uns aux autres anti mac
pourtant la constitution prévoit que les
collectivités locales bénéficient d'une
autonomie financière
qu'en pensez vous c'est selon la libre
administration ça c'est ça c'est vrai
mais c'est toujours en france est
toujours à mi chemin et je pense que
c'est un des gangrènes c'est ça c'est
qu'on n'a pas fait un choix à la fois
dont la libre administration milliards
entre 80 et 100 milliards d'euros de
dotations d'état versées à ces
collectivités
donc soit on est réellement autonome et
on
on se sont gère ses impôts locaux gèrent
ces dépenses on n'a pas d'être de l'état
là on est dans un système mixte et je
pense que c'est ça qui crée le biais
c'est cette espèce de on est responsable
sans l'être à total et qui soit vraiment
indépendante c'est la nouvelle calédonie
qui peut garder ses impôts non parce que
je voulais dire c'est que je trouve que
la décentralisation était gérée en
france avec une culture présidentielle
qui restait là et qu'au fond chaque
président de région par exemple c'est
devenu président dans sa propre région
mena on a toute une série de président
et on n'a pas réfléchi notamment quand
on parle collectivités à l'articulation
entre les différents niveaux on a même
multiplié les niveaux et du coup
aujourd'hui il ya quand même une source
de dépenses de fonctionnement qui est
très élevé dans les collectivités
locales
et ça s'est payé par les contribuables
s'est payé par nous et on parle sans
cesse de rationalisation des dépenses de
l'état mais la question de la
rationalisation des dépenses publiques
au niveau territorial des dépenses de
personnel notamment est un précieux
alors justement l'autonomie parlé ce
matin des fonctionnaires territoriaux
dans une page de vous aurez pc si on l'a
vu c'est quoi le notamment les le temps
de travail c'est le lay direction il ya
un gros point de friction 5 sur le temps
de travail en c2 un rapport de philippe
leroux qui est important a laissé le
maire de sceaux annonce est pas c'est
pas un anti élu local du tout et qui a
fait un rapport montrant que les
fonctionnaires locaux travaillent moins
que les 35 heures voilà donc la
considérerons peuvent confirmer à une
collectivité sur 5 ya vraiment beaucoup
de dérives 1 par clientélisme passer les
petits barons locaux d affirmer chante
quand tu lis ça je ne sais pas comme ça
mais il ya eu de ça il ya une part de
et puis à un empilement des selon l'état
restait aussi malgré tout voulu garder
des antennes qui ce qui se dédoublent
qui sait en tête du coup elle sert
souvent arrivé à la seconde elle restait
tout le monde aux 35 heures est là il
essaye en tout cas on peut en se mariant
avec les particularismes
mais j'ai vu que dans dans l'article que
l'on gardait les journées du mail non
mais c'est quand même serré la vis ils
interdisent maintenant les accords
dérogatoires datant de 2001 qui était
dérogatoire et des interdits donc là où
il faut quand même un gros pas en avant
ils valent aussi harmoniser toutes les
règles de congés spéciaux maternité
paternité des cetc dans toute la
fonction publique pour éviter aussi les
dérives là je considère comme l état et
l art et la récente et là il faut quand
même un boulot qui est bien travaillé
deux gendarmes qui est pas très facile à
faire et qui s'y attaquent
je ne sais pas encore forcément on va
aider d'aider des voix et par ailleurs
le précédent gouvernement avait aussi un
peu essayé ans en passant c'est quand
même assez drôle lassalle misse une
circulaire demandant d'appliquer des
règles de ton travail d'absence et c est
savoir qu'elle avait été
cette circulaire est la réunion était
boycotté par les syndicats c'est quand
même un peu incroyable ya quand même une
chose on doit dire c'est par exemple la
circulation entre les deux fonctions
publiques entre la fonction publique
d'état et la fonction publique
territoriale est pratiquement est
extrêmement difficile pratiquement nul
et on n'arrête pas de nous parler de
rationalisation mais pour commencer il
faudrait peut-être imaginer qu'il puisse
y avoir des carrières qui ce qui se met
en place
alors qu'aujourd'hui les services de
l'état déconcentré comme on dit viennent
souvent doublonner sur ce que font ce
que font les services des collectivités
locales et puis juste une petite chose
pour terminer la question des dépenses
sociales me semble quand même être un
vrai sujet c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
c'est les départements qu'assume la très
grande majorité des dépenses sociales
là il ya un vrai sujet puisque matheron
concert c'est pognon dingue et en même
temps c'est la responsabilité des
départements
donc qu'est ce qui peut se passer sur ce
champ alors même que la question de la
pauvreté la question de la montée des
inégalités très forte je crois qu'il
faut raisonner sur le champ une
rationalisation fonctionnement ça me
semble très clair mais arrêté au niveau
des collectivités locales de ménager les
personnels et compagnie parce qu'au fond
c'est du clientélisme électoral et
regarder les fonctions qu'il faut
assurer pour que la société française
continue à tenir ensemble et l'on nous
dit l'autonomie des régions et le début
de l'europe fédérale des régions donc la
fin de la france
c'est inacceptable ça c'est le gros lot
en question moto vers lé les lois de
décentralisation et pat depuis des
années l'état jette des milliards pour
les banlieues et pour nous rien dans nos
campagnes
s'il modère un peu le flou
non il ya pas mal d'argent qui partent
malgré tout sur les campagnes par les
dotations aussi les dotations sont il me
semble que l'état n'est pas le mieux
placé pour donner des leçons de bonne
gestion aux régions quand tu te le quand
on sait à quel point l'état est
incapable de se réformer c'est un autre
puis un autre sujet pourrait quand même
un petit peu le même sujet aussi et moi
il me semble que le l'histoire va de
plus en plus vers une généralisation
vers une décentralisation
or là
à force de vouloir de se croire
exemplaires ce qu'il n'est pas l'état va
me semble-t-il à contre-courant de
l'histoire mais enfin bon alors vous
demandé sur twitter le gouvernement at
il du dédain pour les collectivités
territoriales
vous êtes 69% à dire que oui on passe à
neutre alors là il ya une troisième
sujet c'est pas rien c'est le poste de
procureur de paris qui est en jeu c'est
l'un des plus exposés aussi on le sait
notamment le refus d'un attentat
terroriste
il va bientôt être vacant son titulaire
françois bolas part à la cour de
cassation
alors avant de nommer son successeur
l'elysée et matignon prennent leur temps
pour choisir le bon candidat le bon
profil
ce qui exaspère les syndicats de
magistrats qui crie à l' ingérence du
politique dans la justice et qui a
également fait réagir
eric ciotti eric ciotti député les
républicains des alpes maritimes
il est dans cette volonté d'imposer sur
la justice des amis et des hommes de
confiance
il a récusé le procureur de lyon qui
était unanimement estimé est reconnu
pour ses compétences c'est extrêmement
grave surtout que ces considérations
bassement politiciennes entrave la
l'intérêt général notamment en matière
de protection des français puisque là il
s'agit de lutter contre le terrorisme
alors la nomination des procureurs eric
ciotti d'ailleurs qui parle du procureur
de lyon en trait termes très élogieux ça
peut être ça vaut pas ce qu'il est
plutôt étiqueté à gauche à l'origine
mais bon passons sur le les programmes
skis à scandale ou pas monsieur schmitt
ailier l'elysée matignon ne font-ils pas
ouvertement ce qu'on a fait pendant des
années discrètement je veux c'est
d'accord avec ce point de vue après la
ce qui se passe c'est qu'apparemment il
ya quand même les trois noms proposés
qui ont été biffés donc ça va loin c'est
à dire que ça va on a l'impression que
les choses se faisaient effectivement
assez hypocritement qui avait des choix
qui étaient en fait des choix politiques
sur les met sur les procureurs c'est
clair après sur le parquet après la
question c'est que la a récusé trois
noms sur trois ça fait quand même
beaucoup et on a le sentiment qu'il ya
une sorte de d'accentuation de 7 ce
contrôle moi je crois que c'est ça le
sujet après j'entendais les syndicats de
magistrats sont pas contents etc
sans doute mais enfin la question c'est
de nommer une personne compétente et le
sujet n'est pas le corporatisme des
marchés des magistrats mais macron ça
tombe mal pour lui parce que comme en ce
moment comme on vient de le dire il est
de toute part accusé autoritaire
verticale et que les signaux se
multiplient depuis la sphère benalla
c'est en quelque sorte un indice de plus
vers 7h tu qualité se pourvoir verticale
et inefficace parce que je pense que si
ça se passait bien à mon avis il y
aurait moins de réactions et je trouve
que juste fournir un mot eric ciotti
c'est quand même le bal des faux culs là
encore c'est à dire qu'elle sait très
bien que la droite comme la gauche ont
toujours pratiqué des nominations
regardons s'ils étaient les mêmes pour
yvan parce qu'effectivement la droite
peut paraître un peu gêné aux
entournures qu'elle n'a jamais défendu
l'indépendance du parquet et elle a
toujours estimé qu'il fallait maintenir
le cordon ombilical s'il terre oui en
effet la droite fait la même chose mais
toute façon sur les institutions fonds
ont fait en sorte que nous n'avons pas
de pouvoir judiciaire mais une autorité
judiciaire c'était une autorité sur le
lien et hiérarchique continue de du
pouvoir exécutif donc il n'ya pas de
séparation entre l'exécutif et le
judiciaire il y en a pas non plus
d'ailleurs entre l'exécutif et le
législatif à ce qu'on a bien vu lors de
la sphère benalla que les commission
denquête répondait aussi au sort de
l'ordre de l'elysée entre parenthèses
c'est d'ailleurs une construction qui
devient un peu problématique quand la
france se permet de donner de donner des
leçons de constitutionnalité à la
pologne par exemple qui est qui est
suspecté de table de m également sa
justice sous surveillance on ferait
mieux de regarder ce que nos propres
problèmes
maintenant si l'on veut une justice on
sait très bien la solution si on veut
une justice qui souhaite qu'ils soient
indépendants il faut élire les juges
comme aux états unis
donc c'est un autre système à partir de
là en effet je suis je vous rejoins en
disant que macron abuse malgré tout de
son autoritarisme en montrant qu il se
défie de tout le monde et y compris
maintenant de son entourage proche et
singulièrement de la deûle à la casse il
doit être assez désagréable poil comme
ça a été désagréable pour le ministre de
l'intérieur donc je vois moi une sorte
de surprise en plus à siéger au coeur de
l'elysée même mais pour le reste cela ne
me choque pas plus que ça sinon que
l'elysée feraient ferait mieux de
s'épargner de donner des leçons alors
que lui-même fera en fait autant et en
fait même pire parce que non seulement
il ya ces liens là mais il ya également
des liens entre l'élysée maintenant et
les médias parce qu'on a entendu la
ministre de
de la communication de la mise de la
culture madame nissen enjoindre
télévision publique de jeu reprend son
terme tout à l'heure de changer les
mentalités sur le terrain et donc si
vous si vous additionnez tous ça vous
dit quand même sa version c'est agathe
serait vous traîner sur un autre terrain
c'est celui de la communication le on
l'a on l'a connu françois molins son l'a
vu souvent dans ses points de presse qui
faisait de façon à ce que la justice
doit savoir communiquer comme l'a fait
françois molins ce au moment des
attentats ou il arrivait quand même à la
fois rassurée expliquez moi je me méfie
quand même de cette tendance à vouloir
un peu trop peut-être politisé justement
le visage de la justice et la fonction
de procureur alors vous me direz c'est
difficile effectivement ce sont des
fonctions qui sont très liés à
l'exécutif et c'est une question
intéressante en terme de philosophie
politique comment on organise la
séparation des pouvoirs
parce que effectivement on a un système
considère effectivement que le l'acte
d'enquêté d'instruire les dossiers doit
relever un monopole de l'état donc
forcément il y a un lien de
subordination inévitable entre la
fonction de procureur et l'exécutif
alors l'alternative effectivement serait
peut-être de s'inspirer de ce qui se
fait dans le modèle anglo saxon je doute
que ce cette solution transportable afin
soit mais bon c'est un débat intéressant
je pense que l'on n'aura jamais de
solution pleinement satisfaisante à mon
avis pour si encore une fois des
fonctions de procureur
alors après je sais que dans les régimes
anglo saxons on a tendance parfois à
privatiser aussi la fonction prirent en
angleterre par exemple au royaume uni il
est beaucoup plus facile pour les
individus pour les communautés qui sont
victimes d'actes criminels de solliciter
de faire le travail entre guillemets de
solliciter détecte procureur privé qui
enquêtent
c'est un modèle anglo saxon qui
complètement différent de notre culture
juridique française mais
l'idée que la justice soit politisé
c'est aussi prendre le risque avec elles
obéissent à aux pulsions aux émotions
des masses et moi j'ai vraiment dans
l'idéal envie d'une justice la plus
froide la plus impartiale possible et
personnalisés peut-être que cécile ça
vous inspire et je sais pas si vous avez
découvert un peu à l'occasion justement
de des attentats et de ses deux visages
est ce que pour vous c'est une bonne
chose qu on personnalise aussi la
justice comme on a tendance à aller
c'est moi je crois que c'était plutôt
une bonne chose en soi dans ce contexte
là ça va la côte est assez rassurant est
à 100 cette personnalisation de la
justice et tarification de certains
jugent cette date des années 80 90 les
revois moins forte aujourd'hui elle est
même peut-être moins forte aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs qu'il n'y avait que les la
gmf aussi la chance de les juger
solution a été testée
après sur le sur le film ocean's
incapacité à par jour d'ios comme
trévidic jean-louis mois la série b qui
n'est plus là les jeunes et pour le
reste et les institutions françaises qui
sont comme ça donc après on change de
rôle armes ont changé ce système mais
c'est un autre débat
quelques réactions si vous voulez bien
sur ce sujet anti mac l'histoire du
procureur de paris c'est une nouvelle
macro nerie est appelée peut-être à
prospérer solis le nouveau monde
ressemble diablement à l'ancien et anti
mac qui poursuit pourquoi n'aurions nous
pas un pouvoir judiciaire comme aux
états unis
vaste question qui prendrait peut-être
au couteau mais enfin on l'a évoqué le
système d'abord vous l'avez bien résumé
yvan et puis le système n'est forcément
pas transposable blueberry cake
il faut élire les juges sont les elysées
ne serait pas aussi laxiste alors
décidément la justice américaine inspire
beaucoup non
maintenant je dis je ça revient à se
politiser a politisé mettre les juges
sous la pression d'une opinion aussi
malgré tout donc que ces positions d'une
élection ça garantissent leurs
compétences et leur indépendance
et l'on nous dit la justice est
complètement politisé et anti mcddi
macro avait déjà trois noms ce qu'on a
évoqué effectivement pourquoi les
récuser tous les trois et bien sûr n'a
compris en tout cas le message officiel
c'était de dire qu' il fallait encore
des profils de renouveau des profils que
les droits étaient trop déjà c'était
carrière est un aboutissement de
carrière en tout cas c'est l'explication
qui a été donné le quatrième du sujet on
va parler de l'aquarius alors 48 heures
ont passé la tension s'est détourné de
l'aquarius une solution européenne a
bien été trouvé pour ses 58 passagers
dont 18 doivent arriver en france les
autres étant répartis entre l'espagne et
le portugal
mais cette gestion coup par coup
peut-elle suffire aux prochains bateaux
de migrants la polémique rebondira sans
doute
alors voici comment emmanuel macron à
justifier cette politique c'était mardi
soir en marge de l'assemblée générale
des nations unies où qui existent aussi
dans notre pays on doit les voir
ensemble si je me mets à dire la france
devient le port d'accueil de tous les
bateaux qui part d'afrique
d'abord ce n'est pas une solution à
laquelle je crois et ensuite ça n'est
pas soutenable même politiquement france
pour nos propres équilibre parce que
toutes celles et ceux qui légitimement
sont inquiets aussi par la force des
migrations est ce que l'europe connaît
depuis plusieurs années diront on a
l'impression qu'ils ne nous protège pas
comme il le devrait et ils auraient
raison il vend sur ce point vous donner
le point à emmanuel macron oui oui bien
sûr mais ce n'est pas tellement lui qui
parle ce sont les populistes qu'il a
derrière et qu'il intime en fait de
changer de politique parce que le
maquereau nismo lui s'ouvrir est bien
volontiers d'ailleurs il l'a terrorisée
ouvrirait bien volontiers au nom des
droits de l'homme de la non
discrimination tout ce que vous voulez à
ces migrants là et c'est vrai que dans
le fond sémillant là ça ne représente
qu'une cinquantaine de personnes ce qui
est absolument rien donc on est dans le
symbole et il est également scellé
baisser la pression symbolique de ce
vote populaire qui ne veut plus entendre
parler de cette immigration qui fait en
plus qui est qui et qui s'introduit dans
le en europe à travers une sorte de
chantage aux bons sentiments auquel se
prêtent
l'aquarius et enfin et certaines des
organisations humanitaires qui qui qui
joue un jeu très ambigu entre les
passeurs et eux-mêmes en facilitant leur
travail donc tout ceci maintenant est
devenu assez irritant et dont je me
félicite en effet d'entendre ce
gouvernement qui est décoré amassé assez
réceptif aux arguments qui tendait à
vouloir accueillir tout le monde se
raidir est en tout cas se raidir sous la
pression de l'opinion mais c'est à dire
quand même mais si je me dis que vous
leur répondez à yvan et plus
généralement est ce que
emmanuel macron a raison de dire qu'un
accueil massif ça fait monter le
populisme et que c'est plus possible
je crois que si compliqué avec un manuel
macron c'est que comme l'ensemble des
chefs d'état en europe que ce qu'il soit
populistes ou se disent progressistes
ils sont en réaction par rapport à une
situation qui ne maîtrisent absolument
pas et pour l'instant ils sont face à
des bateaux où il ya beaucoup moins par
exemple on n'est au niveau de nos
migrants de 2012 donc on n'est plus dans
la crise migratoire dans son caractère
est due à laquelle par exemple angela
merkel avait réagi en accueillant des
centaines
voilà des centaines de milliers de
migrants est ce le fait qu'elle se
trouve aujourd'hui en situation
difficile est sans doute lié au fait
qu'elle a accueilli beaucoup de migrants
donc moi je suis pas en train de nier la
réalité
simplement ce que je constate c'est que
en politique lorsqu'on se dit
progressiste
on doit aller à l'offensive et je ne
trouve pas que maniema qu'on soit à
l'offensé sur ce sujet je pense que
chaque arrivée de bateau se traduit par
des négociations
ridicule parce que c'est 50 personnes 60
personnes en ce moment où 100 personnes
et à chaque fois folle et répartis entre
trois à quatre pays et à chaque fois on
a droit à un très grand discours
ampoulés nous disons que c'est
merveilleux et qu' il ya eu un partage
des responsabilités entre pays européens
est de plus en plus quelle que soit la
famille politique à laquelle on
appartient on voit que c'est une langue
de bois
donc la question c'est comment est ce qu
on entre de nouveau dans la réalité par
rapport à ce qui se passe en
méditerranée et donc il faut évidemment
aller voir du côté des pays d'où
viennent les migrants moi je regardais
par exemple si tu sais pas c'est au
maroc puisque vous savez que c'est les
garde-côtes marocains qui ont tué une
marocaine de 22 ans
eh bien il ya eu un espèce d'immense
débat qui a commencé à apparaître au
maroc parce que c'est des marocains
contre une marocaine donc il ya quelque
chose qui est en train de se passer en
afrique
du côté de ces pays d'où viennent les
migrants sur l'idée de comment est ce
qu'on fait pour arrêter une situation où
au fond ce sont des gens de chez nous
qui meurent l'europe visiblement ne
pourra pas les accueillir
donc moi je trouve qu'il faut reprendre
l'offensive et je trouve que le discours
d' emmanuel macron sur la protection
je le trouve assez faible je pense qu'il
est temps qu'ils disent l'europe ça ne
fonctionne pas voilà ce que je propose
est c est pas seulement
dublin 2 qui est un truc
incompréhensible pour les sociétés il
n'a pas la solution tout simplement
solutions les plus actifs
je crois que ceux dits créatif alors
mauvaise solution situations d'urgence
qu'il faut bien gérer dans l'urgence
fergane ou
comme le dit lucile il faut reprendre le
problème à la base et ne pas laisser
comme ça gouvernée par les sondages
je pense que accueillir les bateaux pas
moi je suis pour une manière jeunes à la
libre circulation des personnes
et effectivement je mets ça va jusqu'où
pas ce que ça veut dire ça comme ça
comme c'était dans l'évidence ce que je
veux dire c'est que aujourd'hui mais ce
qui me frappe avec le continent européen
c'est que on est face à 58 personnes sur
un compte de 500 millions d'habitants et
on panique sur notre incapacité
effectivement à gérer ces flux de
personnes
moi je reprend l'histoire des migrations
en occident et notamment dans un grand
pays comme les etats-unis où on a connu
des vagues migratoires qui était
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus puissante
celle qu'on connaît aujourd'hui est ce
qu'on interroge à metz et quelles sont
les conditions institutionnelles qui
font qu'on arrive à absorber plus
facilement des flux de migrants à telle
ou telle époque aux états unis on a
connu des vagues de migration au 19e et
20e siècles de population de de plein de
régions ou de plein de cultures
différentes c'est un pays qui a réussi à
assimiler ça peut plus les gens puissent
y avait des institutions beaucoup plus
flexible beaucoup plus ouverte
un marché du travail une économie
beaucoup plus ouverte qui permettaient
aux individus qui arrivait sur le
continent américain de s'insérer dans la
société beaucoup plus facilement en
europe on est empêtré dans des
institutions rigide des états providence
qui exclut qui rendent l'accès au marché
du travail compliqué du coup toute
sereinité font qu effectivement quand il
ya 100 personnes qui arrivent on ne sait
plus comment les intégrer on ne sait
plus comment les inclure moi je préfère
question à l'époque par exemple
tensionnelle
on n'a pas du tout la même histoire que
celle des états unis c'est la
comparaison ne vaut pas parce que les
états unis se sont construits sur une
immigration
l'europe est une vieille europe qui
naturellement s'est construit sur une
immigration a trahi européenne bien sûr
il ya eu des passages entre les italiens
les français etc
on a eu droit à une oreille qui ont été
allemands italiens etc
si on a posé de problème à personne mais
aujourd'hui c'est son seul set c'était
une civilisation c'est une immigration
de civilisation qui qui qui pose
problème
et d'ailleurs et vous voyez bien que
quand valence par exemple en espagne le
port de valence accueilli les bras
ouverts l'aquarius justement c'était
l'aquarius il ya deux ou trois mois
immédiatement il ya eu un flux de
clandestins qui sont passés par dessus
les barrières de ceux de ces états de
salt adam territoire marocain avec 2,13
et d'une manière très agressive avec des
prisons des agressions contre les gardes
les militaires qui les militaires
espagnols avec des vraies scènes alors
élevé des vraies scènes d'invasion cette
fois ci et vous remarquerez que
maintenant on n'entend plus parler d'eux
les appels de valence à vouloir
accueillir à nouveau l'aquarius et leur
qu'il n'avait pris que deux cents
personnes de mémoire donc c'est se sont
dits d'accord mais on est on est quand
vous dites 50 personnes je suis bien là
et goussé c'est absolument dérisoire
mais c'est encore une fois ce sont des
symboles qui sont lancés précisément à
ceux qui sont qui sont candidats au
départ et qui voit où nos faiblesses ou
nos origines ou rigidité donc il faut
mieux faire preuve de faux bien envoyer
comme message un message du rigidité de
ferme était plutôt qu'un message de
faiblesse
c'est ce que c'est l'analyse qu'a dû
faire macro pas une grande spécialiste
mais en tout cas ce qui me fera dans
l'émigration je pense qu'elles vont
durer la l'écart démographique entre
l'afrique et l'europe il ya quand même
un sujet là important et je suis assez
d'accord ce qu'est ce qu'il dit c'est
comme le niveau de vie s'accroît en
afrique subsaharienne ça va plutôt
tendance apparaît migration parce que
les gens vont avoir le moyen de partir
ça c'est assez évident après je pense
que là où c'est très difficile pour
l'europe mais moi j'ai pas la solution
c'est qu'on arrive celle se produise
amont il ya une crise aussi de la
civilisation européenne des choses ont
changé ce qu'était l'europe en 1950
avec une société qui était plus
patriarcal c'est un fait ou les familles
divorcées pas où le catholicisme
protestantisme était présent prégnant et
aux mesures pratiquer une religion
aujourd'hui a énormément date et c d
changement majeur de société et dans une
société qui est en plein bouleversement
qui voilà qui en pleine crise d'identité
de au sens vraiment profond et même sans
immigrés elle aurait été en crise
d'identité là dessus harry par dessus
une population qui ne viennent une
civilisation différentes
forcément ça crée beaucoup beaucoup de
difficultés mais si on avait si on était
une société j'imagine
j'avais avec avec une indigne identité
beaucoup plus forte beaucoup plus
affirmée beaucoup plus stable avec moins
de crise voilà deux ans de prison je
pense vraiment proche du terme de
changement ce serait très différent
c'est une immigration si nous n'étions
pas nous-mêmes fait pas facile nous ne
doutions pas nous mêmes de ce que nous
sommes c'est un peu actuelle c'est que
de toute façon nous n'empêcherons pas la
migration c'est à dire que la vérité
c'est qu'elle se produit que macron
parle ou pas à l'onu elle elle se
produit elle est due à des facteurs de
plus en plus multiple par exemple les
migrations climatiques qui est énorme et
on n'est pas on ne sait pas ce qui va se
passer c'est ça la vérité c'est qu'on
ayant peur la migration nous avons peur
de l'avenir et en même temps nous ne
pouvons rien faire contre le fait que
les migrants pour continuer que la
migration va plutôt se développer non je
n'ai aucun l'australie australie a dit
on passe par la libération de passe plus
mais je crois pas que nous soyons dans
la situation de l'australie
géographiquement chéri vent qui est qui
est totalement isolé dans l'océan
pacifique
non mais nous sommes bons nous avons
nous avons déconseillé nous allons des
frontières terrestres nous avons laissé
la grèce et l'italie dans une situation
dramatique nous avons essayé de négocier
avec la turquie pour nous débarrasser de
notre responsabilité sur l'immigration
est donc en fait on est dans une
situation plus grave qui a trois quatre
ans alors qu'à ce moment là on aurait pu
traiter les choses d'une manière plus
unis la deuxième chose que je voulais
dire c'est que il faut traiter aussi les
choses par rapport au territoire
quand j'ai travaillé sur les questions
migratoires et j'ai vu comment dans des
petits villages des petites villes on
avait peur de l'arrivée des migrants
parce qu'ils étaient différents ça
rejoint ce qu'on se disait sur la
question des discriminations
il faut aussi que l'état français les
agents français soient capables d'aller
parler aux personnes et pas seulement de
faire des grands discours
et d'expliquer qu' on va mettre
dix personnes 20 personnes 30 personnes
si on veut accueillir des migrants et
même 50 personnes ça voudra dire
s'adresser aux enseignants s'adresser au
maire et pour le vent accueillent les
migrants vous voyez ce qui se passe en
banlieue pas quand même regarder ouvrez
les yeux
voyez ce que sont devenus les banlieues
dans les ghettos ouailles et 60 au luxe
et contre-société je vous habillez vous
appelez migrants des gens là n'a demandé
la nationalité française
on donne encore quelques réactions
pourra pas prolonger le débat anti mac
ivan a raison nacre ont agi parce qu'il
a peur de l'opinion au delà des mers
c'est le pseudo de notre internaute
l'aquarius n'est que la toute petite
pointe de l'iceberg des mafias qui
organise ces immigrations d'un sujet
dont on a déjà pas mal parler ici d'un
point de vue et leurs maquereaux et
coincé s'il continue il ya la
possibilité que marion maréchal passe
aux prochaines présidentielles c'est un
pronostic
j'aurais juste qu'on s'arrête sur notre
sondage vous l'avez dire en titre
sondage à paraître demain dans le figaro
sondages aux hawks à denso consulting
alors vous êtes trois quarts a approuvé
le refus des manuels macron d'accueillir
l'aquarius et vous êtes également près
de 60% a estimé que la solution
européenne est la bonne mais elle est
majoritairement rejetée par les
sympathisants les républicains et
rassemblement national cette solution
pour au pn on fera pas le tour du sujet
aujourd'hui lors de cas merci d'avoir
contribué à faire avancer le débat
merci beaucoup à tous les quatre et vous
avez rendez vous demain avec guillaume
roquette pour un nouveau point de vue
[Musique]